[Music]  you know  [Music]  one of these villagers like us traveling  forwards through time the other one's  going backwards  can you tell which is which  how about now  why does it feel so strange you're not  shooting the bullet  you're catching it whoa i didn't win  back in my cell  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  for a diplomat there are people in the  future  who need us  [Music]  you get something i'm not gonna like  time isn't the problem getting out alive  is a problem  [Music]  well i'm going so any tips will be  welcome ain't no timer  what do you think we're saying  the detritus of a coming  [Music]  you want to crash a plane well how big a  plane  that part is a little dramatic  last time it was no tennis pg-13  [Music]  you